charlie feels and i agree that we  are the beatles  of basic cable late night which beetle  would you do you think you are then if  definitely paul  yeah  okay if you're paul which beetle am i  which beetle do you think i am  i think you're a little bit of paul i  think you're paul too i think you're  paul  [Music]  if you guys call me ringo i swear to  [ __ ]  i swear to god i think we oh george  harrison you know jordan  maybe john i mean you're definitely  harrison like you know like uh  yeah  john lennon  he was about to give me john lennon well  in terms of the relationships that he  was he was a new one you got a little  john lennon too you got a little john  lennon we're all a little bit of paul  mccartney a little bit of john lennon  george harrison yeah yeah we're all  three ego maniacs right you think we're  the words  [Music]